Поліцейські нудьгують під будівлею Оболонського суду,
де слухається справа про держзраду Віктора Януковича.
Мітингувальники сюди вже давно не приходять.
У залі немає ані активістів, ані спостерігачів.Лише ЗМІ.
Журналісти чують те, що ще чотири роки тому могло б стати"інформаційною бомбою".
Прокурори зачитують раніше засекречені доповіді спецслужб
тодішньому очільнику держави про агресивні плани Росії проти України.
Ідеться про дуже небезпечну активність російських військ у Криму,
повномасштабну російську експансію в економіці, активність угромадському секторіі про те,
що координує це все міжвідомча група в Кремлі на чолі з контррозвідкою та ФСБ.
...що підтверджує факт його обізнаності щодозагроз національній безпеці України,
які існували в той час.
Головна мета прокурорів - довести у суді скоєння Януковичем злочинів,
передбачених трьома статтями КПК - держзрада, сприяння веденню агресивної війни
та вчиненні умисних дій з метою зміни меж території та кордонів України.
Для захисників і колишніх партнерів Янукович - не "обвинувачений", а"четвертий президент України".
Адвокати наполягають, що влади його позбавили насильницьким способом.
А до того, мовляв, Янукович зробив усе необхідне, щоб протидіяти російській агресії.
Тож за те, що сталося після втечі,відповідати має не він.
Наразі жоден свідок і жоден матеріал справи не підтверджує ці обставини.
Надані обвинуваченням докази, утім, доводять:
президент і його адміністрація знали про імовірність російської окупації ще у лютому 2014-го.
Про те, що запобіжних заходів не було вжито, суду розповіли і майже 30 свідків обвинувачення.
Головним же чином обвинувачення будується навколо листа,
який Янукович написав президенту РФ Путіну 1 березня 2014-ого року.
У ньому, вже перебуваючи в Росії, позбавлений повноважень Янукович
просив ввести російські війська на територію України.
Цього листа, імовірно, не достатньо, аби повноцінно довести у суді скоєння Януковичем злочинів,
у яких його обвинувачують, переконаний один з адвокатів родин героїв Небесної сотні Віталій Титич.
Ясно, що всі дії громадянина Януковича
не тільки в останні дні чи в якісь там дні 13-го - початку 14-го року,
а за весь період його дій як державної особи,
коли він вже був в публічному просторіі на поверхні - з 2004 року
Вони вже мають ознаки держзради і мали би на цей предмет досліджуватися.
Фактично за лаштунками судового процесу, на думку адвоката,
залишилисябільш важливі докази держзради.
Приміром, підписання Харківських угод в обмін на продовження перебування російських військ
у Криму, комплекс заходів, що звели нанівець боєготовність української армії
до початку російської агресії.
Адвокат Титич вважає, що прокуратура спростила собі роботу,
і має цьому два можливих пояснення.
В кращому випадку влада поспішає завершити процес над Януковичем до виборів.
Але не виключений і інший сценарій.
Негативний сценарій полягає, на мою думку, в тому, що існують домовленості між тим же Януковичем,
умовно кажучи,і його захистом іпрокуратурою,
що кожен в цьому процесі реалізує свої небезкоштовні, думаю, домовленості
чи якісь інші преференції.
На думку адвоката, судовий процес над Януковичем вже давно перетворився
на"затяжний юридичний фейк".
Тож Титич не виключає, що без аргументованої доказової бази
у майбутньому вирок Віктору Януковичу може бути скасований в українських чи європейському судах.